ما يجري على الله قد ذهب في الماضي أو
الآن
كل هذه العقوبات المزعومة تمنع
الافتقار إلى الاستثمارات الافتقار إلى هذه
إرادتهم تلتف
أه إلى شيء واحد وشيء واحد فقط
نقص إمدادات الطاقة
من جميع الأنواع عندما تكون في أمس الحاجة إليها
هذا هو قلقي وهذا شيء
لا أريد أن أكون مسؤولاً عن ما
كنت أحذر
الناس بشأنه من الاستمرار في تحذير الناس
من
هذا المسار الكامل للمستقبل
قد
يضيع بسبب الجهل
مرة أخرى وأعد الناس بأن يكونوا كذلك.  بقدر ما
تحصل عليه هذه وجهة نظري الشخصية ، فأنا من
حقني أن أراها شخصًا غير
مسيّس ، فليس هذا كمواطن
مسؤول
في هذا العالم
أريد أن أتأكد من أنك بصريًا الأشخاص
الذين يفهمون أن
ما يحدث اليوم قد يقودني على الأرجح
أنا مخطئ للغاية ، أتمنى أن أكون
مخطئًا للغاية ،
لكنني لا أتوقع أو أتوقع ،
لكني آمل ألا يؤدي ذلك إلى
نقص في إمدادات الطاقة ، وليس
إمدادات النفط ، وليس إمدادات الغاز ، ولكن
إمدادات الطاقة عندما تكون في أمس الحاجة إليها